Russian scumbags continue to
turn around once I immediately saw two
people, a man and a woman, the woman
did not show signs of life With
practical sabotage, everyone knows very well
that there are residential areas here, there is
generally a hint of some kind of military
sandy infrastructure in general
in the morning when people go to study,
how I was lying on the couch, everything flew
in from it, I have all the furniture battered in the apartment
everything in the world everything is in holes everything These
are the same bullets these scales
CT hissing
with different lie down on the floor Well on the ground
more precisely Here is the
first  arrival 5 entrance here
[music]